>> Laura: I DON'T NEED ANY
MORE HEAT, HOT ENOUGH, SEAN.
THANK YOU SO MUCH.
GREAT SHOW TONIGHT, AS ALWAYS.
THANK YOU, SEAN, WE, WE'LL
CONTINUE THE CONVERSATION ABOUT
THE LIFE OF BARBARA BUSH AND A
LOT MORE.
GOOD EVENING FROM WASHINGTON.
I'M LAURA INGRAHAM AND
MRS. "THE INGRAHAM ANGLE."
WE BEGIN WITH CONTINUING
COVERAGE OF THE PASSING OF
FIRST LADY BARBARA BUSH.
THE FORMER FIRST LADY DIED TODAY
AT HER HOME IN HOUSTON, AS SEAN
SAID, AT AGE 92.
SHE WAS ONE OF ONLY TWO WOMAN IN
U.S. HISTORY TO BE BOTH THE
MOTHER AND THE WIFE OF A U.S.
PRESIDENT.
BARBARA BUSH WAS SPECIAL AND SO
MANY OTHER WAYS.
SHE WAS DOWN TO EARTH AND ALSO
DIGNIFIED.
SHE WAS ELEGANT.
SHE WAS ADMIRED, SHE WAS LOVED
BY AMERICANS AND POLITICIANS ON
BOTH SIDES OF THE AISLE, WHICH
DOESN'T SEEM POSSIBLE TODAY.
TRIBUTES ARE POURING IN FROM
FAMILY, FRIENDS, AND OTHERS,
WHOSE LIVES SHE TOUCHED HER.
JOINING US TONIGHT FOR A LOOK AT
THE LEGACY OF THIS REMARKABLY
GRACIOUS AND KIND WOMAN ARE
BRET BAIER, NEWT GINGRICH,
KARL ROVE, AND BRIT HUME.
IT IS GREAT TO SEE ALL OF YOU
TONIGHT ON THIS AT NIGHT.
I WANT TO START WITH YOU,
KARL ROVE.
WHAT A LIFE, WHAT A LADY.
THE TRIBUTES FROM EVERYBODY,
FROM BILL CLINTON TO FOREIGN
LEADERS, DEMOCRATS, LIBERALS,
CONSERVATIVES, AND WITH TODAY'S
POLITICS, IT IS KIND OF
REFRESHING ALL OVER AGAIN TO
HEAR HOW MANY PEOPLE LOVED HER
SO MUCH.
>> A RATHER FERMENTABLE
PRESENCE.
A WOMAN OF GREAT CHARACTER, OF A
FOR ENORMOUS VALUES.
THERE IS GOING TO BE A BIG
WELCOME PARTY FOR HER.
BUT I'M SURE THE AUTHORITIES IN
HEAVEN ARE MAKING SURE THAT
EVERYBODY'S ON THEIR BEST
BEHAVIOR BECAUSE MRS. BUSH HAD
AN EXPECTATION THAT YOU ARE
CAPABLE OF DOING GOOD THINGS AND
SHE WOULD LET YOU KNOW IF SHE
FELT YOU WERE -- HE COULD DO A
LITTLE BIT MORE TO ACHIEVE WHAT
SHE THOUGHT WAS POSSIBLE.
I MET HER WHEN I WAS 22 AND I
HAVE -- A SMILE THAT COULD LIGHT
UP THE ROOM.
A WARMTH, A RESPECT FOR
EVERYONE, FUN TO BE AROUND,
BRASH, SMART, REALLY SMART, AND
CAPABLE OF, MANY A TIME I SAW
HER NEEDLE POINTING AND YOU
WOULD THINK THAT SHE WOULD
FOCUSED ON THE NEEDLE POINTING
AND THEN SHE WOULD INJECT INTO
THE CONVERSATION AND YOU KNEW
SHE HAD BEEN PAYING ATTENTION TO
EVERY SINGLE WORD THAT YOU HAD
BEEN SAYING.
I WAS SUPPOSED TO HAVE LUNCH
WITH THEM TWO WEEKS AGO TODAY
AND SHE WENT INTO THE HOSPITAL
ON MONDAY.
SHE WAS A REMARKABLE PRESENCE
AND THINK ABOUT IT, ADVISOR TO A
PRESIDENT, HUSBAND, HER HUSBAND,
WHOM SHE LOVED DEARLY, MET HIM
WHEN SHE WAS 16, FELL IN LOVE
WITH HIM, MARRIED, TOGETHER FOR
NEARLY 76 CLEARED, MARRIED FOR
73, I MEAN REALLY REMARKABLE.
HARD TO MATCH UP THAT.
>> Laura: NEWT GINGRICH, ONE
OF THE GREAT THINGS ABOUT HER,
THERE ARE SO MANY GREAT THINGS
ABOUT HER, IS SHE DOESN'T HAVE A
LOT OF PRETENSE.
SHE WAS COMMENTING FIRST ABOUT
BECOMING THE VICE PRESIDENT
WIFE, SHE SAID A LOT OF FAT,
WHITE HAIRED LADIES WHO ARE
WRINKLED ARE TICKLED PINK ABOUT
MY ASCENDING TO THIS ROLE.
SHE IS JUST SO FUN.
SHE DIDN'T DYE HER HAIR, GET A
FACE-LIFT.
SHE'S LIKE, I AM WHO I AM.
THAT IS SO REFRESHING TODAY.
I USE THE WORD REFRESHING, BUT I
LOVE IT.
>> AT ONE POINT SHE DESCRIBED
HERSELF AS THE NATION'S
GRANDMOTHER.
AND I THINK AT THAT SORT OF
CAPTURED IT.
AND AT THAT POINT, I THINK SHE
HAD 25-POINT OH OR HIGHER
APPROVAL RATING THAN HER
HUSBAND.
WE WERE TALKING EARLIER TONIGHT,
WHAT A REMARKABLE COUPLE, AND
KARL CALLED IT RIGHT.
SHE WAS FEROCIOUS.
SHE WAS PLEASANT, SHE WAS NICE,
BUT IN TERMS OF BOTH HER HUSBAND
AND HER SONS, IN TERMS OF JOB'S
CAMPAIGN, GEORGE Ws CAMPAIGN,
THERE WAS NO QUESTION SHE WAS
GOING TO GO ALL OUT AND
REACH EVERYONE SHE COULD, A
REMARKABLE AMERICAN FAMILY.
>> FIRST OF ALL, THAT LOVE
AFFAIR WAS REALLY A LOT OF WHO
SHE WAS.
LOVE AFFAIR WITH HW BUSH, 41,
AND WITH HER FAMILY.
TODAY, WE ARE TOLD THAT H&W HELD
HER HAND ALL DAY LONG NEXT TO
HER AND THAT SHE WAS SURROUNDED
BY FAMILY AND HE WAS RIGHT NEXT
TO HER WHEN SHE LEFT THE EARTH.
I THINK YOU ARE SEEING THIS
FAMILY RALLY AROUND EACH OTHER.
IT WAS A BIG PART OF THEIR LIFE
TO BE TOGETHER.
SHE SAID THAT IT WAS THE MOST
IMPORTANT THING IN HER LIFE AND
SHE GAVE A LOT OF COMMENCEMENT
ADDRESSES.
ONE OF THEM AT WESLEY COLLEGE
SAID "AT THE END OF YOUR LIFE,
YOU WILL NEVER REGRET NOT
HAVING PASSED ONE MORE TEST, NOT
WINNING ONE MORE VERDICT OR NOT
CLOSING ONE MORE DEAL, YOU WILL
REGRET TIME NOT SPENT WITH YOUR
HUSBAND, A CHILD, FRIEND, OR A
PARENT."
>> Laura: THAT IS FOR SURE.
WE ALL THINK THAT IN OUR LIVES,
IT GOES BY REALLY FAST.
WE ACTUALLY HAVE ANOTHER MOMENT
FROM THAT SAME ADDRESS AT
WELLESLEY COLLEGE, BRIT HUME, I
WANT YOU TO REACT TO THIS.
LET'S WATCH.
>> I WANT TO OFFER A NEW LEGEND,
THE WINNER OF THE HOOP RACE WILL
BE THE FIRST TO REALIZE HER
DREAM, NOT SOCIETY'S DREAM HER
OWN PERSONAL DREAM.
WHO KNOWS, SOMEWHERE OUT IN THIS
AUDIENCE, MAY EVEN BE SOMEONE
WHO WILL ONE DAY FOLLOW IN MY
FOOTSTEPS AND PRESIDE OVER THE
WHITE HOUSE AS THE PRESIDENT'S
SPOUSE I WISH HIM WELL.
>> Laura: WE CUT TO THE CROWD
THERE BUT THE CROWD, BRIT, WENT
CRAZY.
THEY ENDED UP LOVING IT.
THERE WAS CONTROVERSY, THOUGH,
ABOUT HER APPEARING.
COMPARED TO WHAT IT WAS LIKE
TODAY, THAT WAS 1990, A
REPUBLICAN GOES TO A COLLEGE
TODAY, IT IS A DIFFERENT
RECEPTION.
THEY ENDED UP LOVING HER THERE.
>> SHE WAS SUPPLEMENT PEOPLE I
THINK -- IT WASN'T THAT SHE WAS
SO CUDDLY.
SHE WHIRLED WASN'T CUDDLY.
SHE WAS WARM AND FRIENDLY AND
SHE WAS OUTGOING, BUT SHE HAD
STANDARDS.
AND YOU KNEW WHEN YOU ARE AROUND
HER.
I ALWAYS FELT THAT I BETTER BE
ON MY BEST BEHAVIOR AROUND HER.
SHE USED TO SAY APROPOS OF HER
DEVOTION TO FAMILY, SHE USED TO
SAY, WHAT HAPPENS AT YOUR HOUSE
IS MORE IMPORTANT AND WHAT
HAPPENS AT THE WHITE HOUSE.
NOT A FEW OFTEN EXPRESSED BUT
ONE THAT AT THE TIME I THINK WAS
TAKEN WHILE AND WAS VERY
MUCH LIKE HER.
SHE WAS VERY FOCUSED ON FAMILY,
HER FAMILY AND PARTICULAR,
FAMILY VALUES, WHICH MAY HAVE
FALLEN OUT OF FAVOR BUT THEY
NEVER DID WITH HER.
>> Laura: AT ONE POINT, SHE
SAID I AM WORRIED ABOUT PARENTS
WHO DON'T PARENTS.
THE SIMPLE THINGS THAT KIND OF
STAY WITH YOU.
KARL, THERE WAS ANOTHER MOMENT
WHERE SHE WAS TALKING ABOUT,
AMONG THE PROFESSIONAL THINGS
THAT SHE DID OR THINGS THAT AS
FIRST LADY WAS HER LITERACY
INITIATIVE THAT REALLY TOOK HOLD
DURING GEORGE Ws TERM.
LET'S WATCH.
>> I DECIDED THAT I WANTED TO DO
SOMETHING THAT WOULD HELP
GEORGE, THAT WOULD HELP THE MOST
AMERICANS POSSIBLE, WITHOUT
COSTING THE GOVERNMENT HUGE
AMOUNTS OF MONEY.
>> YOU CAN GO TO HOSPITAL AND
READ TO CHILDREN.
YOU CAN DO THAT.
I DON'T THINK MANY PEOPLE THINK
ME FOR THE LITERACY.
>> Laura: SHE GOT A LITTLE BIT
ANNOYED BY THAT.
YOU DON'T BLAME HER.
IT'S IN EVERY STATE, SHE RAISED
TENS OF MILLIONS OF DOLLARS,
FAMOUS AUTHORS LIKE
NEWT GINGRICH AND BRET BAIER, TO
GO AND SPEAK, SHE SAID I WILL
NEVER PAY YOU, YOU'RE DOING IT
FOR FREE, AND THEY SAID, YOU BET
I WILL DO IT FOR FREE, NO
PROBLEM.
I LOVE THE LITERACY.
I THINK SHE DOES NOT GET ENOUGH
CREDIT FOR THAT.
AND IT'S FAMILY LITERACY THAT
SHE SAYS HOLDS FAMILIES
TOGETHER.
FAITH, FAMILY, LITERACY, READING
>> ABSOLUTELY RIGHT.
THIS WAS A GREAT PASSION FOR
HER.
THE FOCUS WAS, IT IS YOUR
RESPONSIBILITY AS A PARENT OR A
FRIEND OR FAMILY MEMBER TO HELP
SOMEONE ELSE LEARN TO LOVE TO
READ.
AND TO DO SO AT AN EARLY AGE.
AND I THINK IT'S REMARKABLE EVEN
TODAY, THE EFFORT GOES ON AND A
HUGE FASHION.
I WANT TO TALK, THOUGH, QUICKLY
ABOUT ONE OTHER THING.
YOU MAY REMEMBER THAT MOMENT
WHEN SHE WAS, THE FIRST LADY OF
THE UNITED STATES, WHEN SHE WENT
TO THE HOSPITAL IN WASHINGTON
AND HELD AN AIDS BABY.
THIS WAS A LOT OF TIME WHEN
PEOPLE THOUGHT PEOPLE THOUGHT AD
PEOPLE THOUGHT PEOPLE THOUGHT AS
PEOPLE THOUGHT PEOPLE THOUGHT AC
PEOPLE THOUGHT PEOPLE THOUGHT AU
PEOPLE THOUGHT PEOPLE THOUGHT AD
PEOPLE THOUGHT PEOPLE THOUGHT AB
PEOPLE THOUGHT PEOPLE THOUGHT AE
COMMUNICATED BY SIMILE TOUCHING
SOMEONE.
A LOT OF THESE BABIES WERE
LACKING CONTACT.
SHE WENT AND DID THAT BECAUSE
SHE WANTED TO SET AN EXAMPLE AND
MAKE IT CLEAR THAT THIS IS ONE
OF THE THINGS, THIS WOMAN, SHE
MAY HAVE WORN FAKE PEARLS AND
SHE MAY HAVE HAD GRAY HAIR, BUT
SHE HAD A RESPECT FOR EVERY
SINGLE HUMAN BEING AND WHICH SHE
CAME IN CONTACT AND EXPECTED
OTHER PEOPLE TO HAVE THAT SAME
MUTUAL RESPECT FOR EVERY ONE OF
GOD'S CREATURES AND EVERY ONE OF
GOD'S PEOPLE.
I THOUGHT IT WAS A POWERFUL
MOMENT WHEN SHE DID THAT, AND
EMBLEMATIC OF THIS GREAT AND
NOBLE WOMAN WHO SERVED OUR
COUNTRY.
SHE WAS VERY PATRIOTIC.
SHE LOVED AMERICA DEEPLY, AND
CHERISHED THE GREAT VALUES THAT
WE HAVEN'T OUR FREEDOMS AND
WANTED OTHERS TO ENJOY AND
RESPECT IN THIS WORLD.
>> Laura: SHE WAS PART OF THE
GREATEST GENERATION.
SHE AND GEORGE H.W. BUSH.
>> THE WHOLE STORY OF A ROMANCE,
REALLY DECIDING TO GET MARRIED
AND THEN HIM GOING OFF TO WAR,
THE YOUNGEST PILOTS IN
WORLD WAR II SHOT DOWN, LUCKILY
SAVED BY AN AMERICAN SUBMARINE.
THERE'S A LOT TO THEIR WHOLE
LIFETIME.
MOVING TO TEXAS, WHICH BACK
THEN, FOR THEM, WAS A PRETTY
RADICAL MOVE.
RUNNING FOR CONGRESS, SERVING AS
HEAD OF THE CIA, EVERYWHERE HE
WENT, SHE WENT.
>> THEIR HOUSE IN MIDLAND TEXAS,
IF YOU'VE EVER BEEN THERE, IS A
VERY MODEST, IT IS PAPER THIN
WALLS, AND AT ONE POINT THEY
WERE LIVING NEXT DOOR TO THE
LOCAL PROSTITUTE WITH WHOM THEY
SHARE DIFFERENT DOOR.
>> THEY DON'T USUALLY DO THAT.
THE PEOPLE WHO WORKED FOR THE
BUSHES LOVED THEM.
HER SECRET SERVICE NAME WAS
TRANQUILITY, HER COAT NAME.
SHE HAD A CERTAIN TOUCH, AS BRIT
SAID, SHE COULD BE FIERY AND
SHARP.
SHE REALLY LOVED PRIVACY.
WHEN SHE LEFT, SHE WAS HURT IN
'92, SHE TOLD THE STORY THAT SHE
WAS IN A STORE AND SOME LADY
CAME UP AND SAID, AREN'T YOU
BARBARA BUSH, SHE SAID, NO,
SHE'S MUCH OLDER THAN ME.
>> Laura: [LAUGHS]
LET'S END WITH BRIT HUME.
THERE WAS A MOMENT DURING THE
2016 CAMPAIGN, WE WERE JUST
HOWLING OUT EARLIER, MY
PRODUCERS, BECAUSE MRS. BUSH WAS
TALKING ABOUT WHAT THE COUNTRY
NEEDS AT THIS POINT.
LET'S WATCH.
>> DO YOU THINK THERE IS ROOM
FOR ANOTHER BUSH IN THE
WHITE HOUSE?
>> I THINK THIS IS A GREAT
AMERICAN COUNTRY, GREAT COUNTRY.
AND IF WE CAN'T FIND MORE THAN
TWO OR THREE FAMILIES TO RUN FOR
HIGH OFFICE, THAT'S SILLY.
>> Laura: [LAUGHS]
WE HAVE JEB BUSH RUNNING, AND
HE'S LIKE, WHAT IS GOING ON
HERE?
HILARIOUS.
>> SHE WAS LATER TO CHANGE YOUR
VIEW OF THAT IF YOU MAY RECALL.
I THINK, AND ALL OF THIS, WE
SHOULD HAVE A PARTICULARLY
NIGHTS.
WHEN I MET HIM AND COVERED HIS
CAMPAIGN BACK IN 1980, THEY HAD
BEEN MARRIED ALREADY FOR 35
YEARS.
THIS MARRIAGE HAS GONE ON, FOR
WHAT, 72, 73 YEARS.
WHENEVER THEY WERE TOGETHER, AS
OTHERS HAVE NOTED, AND RECENT
YEARS IN PARTICULAR, THEY WERE
ALWAYS HOLDING HANDS.
ONE OF THE GREAT MARRIAGES OF
OUR TIME.
HERE HE IS, AS LATE AS HE IS IN
HIS LIFE, HAVING TO ENDURE THIS
LOSS, WE'VE ALL LOST SOMETHING
TONIGHT BUT HIM MOST OF ALL.